let's talk about amazon okay amazon
on a hiring spree without equal the
company has added 427
300 employees in 10 months bringing this
global workforce to more than 1.2
million that's an average of 1400 new
workers a day let me say that one more
time that's an average of 1400 new
workers they hired per day and
solidifying its power as an online
shopping becomes more entrenched on the
chronovirus pandemic the high rank has
taken place at amazon's headquarters in
seattle at its hundredths
of warehouses and rural communities and
suburbs and in countries such as india
and italy
uh with its new employees they hired
that's 50 higher than last year
the spree has accelerated since the
onset of the pandemic
uh which has turbocharged amazon's
business and made its winner of the
crisis
uh starting in july the company brought
on board 350 000 employees 25 2800 they
most have been warehouse workers but
amazon has also hired software engineers
and
hardware specialists to power
enterprises such as cloud computing
stemming
streaming entertaining entertainment and
devices which has
boomed in the pandemic okay 427 300
employees
tom thoughts i think this is amazing so
for all those people that were saying
amazon's not hiring anybody they're just
going to put robots and all the
warehouses and everything
hey you're wrong baby they're hiring
people this is a good point
it may not may not be a job that
everybody wants but there's a bunch of
jobs out there
in a clean warehouse where you can get
some basic benefits and
get a job what do you think about the
protesting people protesting saying
you're not
paying them well enough you're not
taking care of them you're working their
tails off it's not fair what do you
think about all the protesting
look you know there's there is not
a ceo out there that hasn't endured
people wanting more
and i don't think that's such a big
surprise and everybody wants a living
wage but look you know if you're a
part-time
worker in a warehouse and everything
maybe that's not you know
a full lifestyle job and so i
i think entrepreneurs take it the chops
too much you're making jobs
you're those everybody's paying a little
bit in taxes you're adding to the
economy
you're making enabled consumers can go
buy other things
and uh somebody's gonna be upset with
you
what do you think about it adam yeah i
mean to echo toms thoughts
um a couple different different thoughts
we we pulled it up last time if you go
to relentless.com
relentless.com i challenge everyone out
there to pull up relentless.com
and see what gets pulled up boom
amazon.com just to kind of put their
mentality out there they bought
relentless.com just to show like they
ain't going nowhere and they're going to
keep hiring hiring hiring
i actually did some research you know
who the largest employers on the planet
are on the
entire planet the largest employers on
the entire planet
i mean it's the government is the the
highest correct number one walmart
yeah is that yeah i know you're you're
you're uh you're absolutely right u.s
defense department 3.2 million people
number two the chinese army uh 2.3
million people what's that the
uh what's the name of the chinese army
the people's freedom movement whatever
it's called
yeah chinese army number three walmart
2.1 million number four
mcdonald's 1.9 million so now where is
that size of 2018 by the way exactly
this
20 is 20. they haven't calculated
2020 data walmart's at 2.4 million okay
gotcha so
i need to step my game up no but but you
got good data they keep going
yeah no the point is that amazon last
year wasn't even on the top 10 list but
now they're
likely to be cros uh cracking the top
five pretty soon
kind of like what tom said you know they
they get a bad name they you know the
robots are gonna put people out of work
they're hiring like crazy what's the
stat here that um
384 000 job applications just um
[Music]
since september 16th it says so look
you're looking for a job
amazon's got you right so um respect to
amazon like we talk about here
entrepreneurs get a bad name but
25 000 of those jobs with an average
salary of 150 000
we're supposed to be in new york until
aoc yeah and de blasio pushed him out
and cuomo said what the hell are you
guys doing
stupid 25 000 jobs at an average salary
of 150 000
was supposed to be in new york and de
blasio and aoc said it's not fair
you're going to come and raise wages and
you're going to raise a lifestyle and
rent's going to go up
like what the hell are you talking about
yeah you got 25 000 jobs at 150
000 and they won elsewhere plus
thousands and thousands of other jobs
those are the high paid workers i mean
obviously the people that are even just
making 15 bucks an hour whatever it is
in new york city that they pushed them
out it's sad did you have another
thought on this yeah just another
thought i mean just to
just to you know maybe end this argument
if not
i would say the two biggest
entrepreneurs are the biggest names in
in
the billionaire names in the world for
the past
few decades have been warren buffett and
bill gates
unquestionably straight up now without
question
you're talking bezos and musk now like
the the new
the new guard is here the old guard
obviously
warren buffett is what 90 years old
somewhere around that i don't know if i
would put gates in the old guard because
i think gates just getting started you
got to realize
gates is how old how will this get bill
gates he's in his mid 60s
that's not old i'm not saying that
that's not or one when you're worth 100
billion dollars guess who's your doctor
he 65 there it is um
yeah 65. who's your doctor when he got
i'm not saying that
i'm not saying he's uh you know
gone but he's clearly not focused on
business as much anymore he's more about
humanity hauser the best doctor in the
world he's
still favorite bill gates's doctor
probably neil patrick harris that's
right
doogee house did you grow up to do you
or not love doogie house yeah i mean
did you mean sarcastically no i'm not
sarcastic i guess you being a doogie guy
i mean i she was a doughy guy in the
melrose place guy yeah i'm more about
doing the dougie kind of a thing than
the doogee houser but can you do the
doggy
no i was i was never able to uh i never
really got into that show
bob tom i've seen you dancing let me
tell you i guarantee you your dance
moves will get a lot more views online
than
than adam's dance moves mine i don't
know about my dance moves keep
chiropractors employed
were you a doogie hauser guy i know i i
just said that i was not a dookie house
never i could see you totally baby
why are you pissing him off he just said
it for the third time he's not a dude
tom's got the kind of a temper of a
scientist don't slap me around
come on let's let's go back to this
topic let's go back somehow yeah somehow
we went from amazon to doogie's yeah
that was i'll take the responsibility
don't believe that but go back to this
time any final thoughts on right here on
amazon you can get all the old doogie
housers
you know i'm sure they've got like a
bunch of links there to the old dvds
they probably do um and you can still
buy them as dvds or download them from
amazon video
you're just plugging amazon over here no
no i'm not trying to plug amazon it's
just uh
you know what's interesting you brought
up there is there's a stat i thought you
had looked up
adam it's like half a minute there's
another half million jobs out there that
amazon's created that are contract jobs
for drivers
right and so you got drivers out there
and you know somebody was just rolling
up here
on one of the comments and was saying
hey don't forget us truckers
uh we get contract jobs on amazon they
move a lot of stuff
and so um what's next for amazon tom i
mean if you're really thinking about it
right now
you know the conversation that came up
yesterday was uh uh monopoly
and and hey is is anybody facing a
monopoly right now and paul said
monopoly is when you want 100 i said
monopoly is not 100
i think the monopolies are 50 rule that
they have if you start getting more than
the target market you start kind of
facing monopoly type of issues used to
be 75 some say 75 some say 50
but states around a 50 number that
you're talking about federal trade
commission's got low radar 51.00 and
then they come visit you in your lobby
is is that visit going to be happening
anytime soon or is
walmart preventing them from being a
monopoly i i think walmart
you know it's interesting to look at i
was the other day i was looking at
target
target very quietly you know didn't want
to just be the number three guy that
just died a lonely death
and they've done a lot with their um
with their online
and delivery on covid but i i believe
that
there is a
move that is coming for amazon and maybe
it's going to slow down under the biden
administration but there is a move
that's coming from a target to compete
with
well yeah i think i think there's a lot
of people want the us government to kind
of
clip their wings a little bit and
because it's not a bad thing if sam's
club and
walmart same thing and target and amazon
are all competing i mean
that helps all of us a little bit let me
tell you the fact that target's in there
target is helping amazon from being uh
uh uh uh you know categorically in
amazon
target's a savior right here for these
guys you take target out both amazon and
walmart are in trouble
because for monopoly question about it
so
jeff bezos is behind closed doors
secretly
secretly wants target to do better jeff
bezos
for optics for competition he's like
listen target keep going at it man take
some markers you think he's rooting for
a market share
a hundred percent rooting for target a
hundred percent he's rooting for target
because when kmart went out of business
about a decade ago i don't know if you
remember kmart was the king car was huge
before
saving center kmart went out hurt a lot
of these guys
but now that uh target's coming up and
there's some people that go to target
over
over walmart there's a lot of people
that prefer kai's one of them
well you know kai flirts that target
that's where he picks up girls
well sam too so some people go to tinder
kai goes to
target that's where he goes to florida
he's doing it in the army at fort
campbell kentucky the place to go flirt
was at walmart at clarksville
nice but that was 24 years ago so it's a
difference how many teeth that those
ladies have
how many teeth yeah you'd be surprised
at least seven nice good communities
nice that's a nice tell us what you got
final thoughts like something that tom
brought up yesterday you you wanted to
talk about uh
you know speaking of where you used to
go pick up chicks and all that fun stuff
you know
kai goes to target uh sam goes to the
mall we talk about the malls here we're
talking about these big
anchor stores the sears the jc penney's
the lord and taylor's what happened now
they're becoming
amazon fulfillment centers and a lot of
these dying malls are going to have to
be
more amusement park crazy fun vibes to i
mean when we can all get out there in
public again
kind of get out there take the family
and and have fun with it but a lot of
these anchor stores will be
or are becoming amazon fulfillment
centers i believe you had a thought with
that did you not with the fulfillment
centers
oh yeah you know i think that so
the malls well first of all commercial
office space is
yeah what we could do a whole discussion
about what's happening in commercial
office space
with work from home and everything well
the case study but i think you know you
get these
you know it's it's not you still have to
go
get stuff right um and i saw a picture
in new york it's very interesting
it was this brownstone had been built
and people can't get in
at night because there's this little
skinny hallway and inside there they're
floor-to-ceiling they have all the
amazon boxes
because they have someone that brings
all the boxes in so the pirates don't
snatch it off the porch
and they're stacked up on the inside and
it used to be you would walk in
you have this little tiny area and you
put your key in you get your mail now
there's just floor to ceiling with all
these amazon boxes
groceries and everything like that i
really think that there's these you take
a look at whole foods they got all the
amazon lockers for little stuff out
front
once you start getting even even bigger
than this it's like all of us are going
to need like something three times the
size of our high school hallway locker
where each day we just go get our stuff
because it's not just
little stuff and i don't know how much
you're going to
be able to deliver so i think commercial
real estate is done like you think it's
going to have a massive decline like new
space
what are we doing with the space you
know what are we going to do but i'm
asking you like like do you think do you
think they're the next newspaper
i don't think they're the next newspaper
but they're in bad
bad places but watch what you're saying
it's a little bit contradictory because
i'm actually really curious with this
tom and i want to give your feedback
because
when elon musk did an interview what was
two years ago when he kept saying the
biggest threat to
humanity is what ai you know
everything's going to be replaced jobs
are going to be replaced
and then you had andrew yanks campaign
which was a thousand dollar
you know basic income you know
everybody's got to get a thousand bucks
because ai
and then amazon employs 427 000 people
during pandemic which everyone's working
from home
do you understand what i just said right
there so during the season where
everybody's working from home
amazon hires 427 000 people and so then
the conversation becomes about
commercial
because i got a lot of commercial real
estate guys that call me and say pat
i disagree with you commercial real
estate is doing very well and people are
always going to need office space i'm
like i don't know if they need
many industries don't need it but
actually from your point of view
do you really think commercial real
estate because we could be as bad as
newspapers or are they still going to
have to figure out where to come back
and recover
i think some of it will be repurposed
and does somebody get smart
and repurpose it so does somebody in
commercial real estate pull a target and
say i'm not going to get crushed i'm
going to find a way to live in this and
i'm going to repurpose my space and
do things like this i think that's the
first avenue the second avenue
is i take a look at something i was
reading and i don't want to plug major
credit card company
right that we all know it's the one with
the highest fees but a lot of services
and it's one you have to pay every month
well they
have like their entire call centers
are working from home they come up they
turn on their headset
they've got these secure loops that
they've done through what's called a vpn
tunnel
so they open up their laptop at home and
they're on duty and they're doing their
stuff looking at your charges looking at
things on there in a secure way
and so the entire call center is working
from home which has eliminated the need
for an atlanta
of phoenix and a miami excess space in
their call centers
so somebody's going to pay out the lease
on those commercial contracts are you
talking about american express
or was that discovery it's your podcast
i was waiting for you to plug it in
but here's here's my question for you
but yes that's right it was amazing
here's my question for you i
i trust your brain and your processing
um
if you if we right now the three of us
own two billion dollars of commercial
real estate
in america pre-pandemic okay we're doing
okay
we're 85 uh you know fully occupancy
we're doing okay
money's coming in we're doing fine and
we're sitting on it
covet hits we lose people a lot of our
guys cannot pay us
what's your next move what are you doing
two billion dollars of commercial real
estate across the country what are we
doing tom well
the first thing that we do is because
all commercial real estate is levered
is even though we're in a coveted
pandemic we
got to go to new york and we got to
refinance that debt because at least
okay so number one move is refinance the
debt what's next yeah so now you gotta
get by the way
if we've got that kind of number we got
two guys that report to
jamie dimon seeing us with that kind of
but that kind of you know i'm sure
yeah that's a big number so first of all
we got to refinance the debt
and the next thing we got to take a look
around on is
how do we make this usable what do you
do with that what do you what do you do
with that
you know you got like old mall space i
think you could do amazon delivery
centers pickup centers there's a lot of
things
interesting it's kind of scary it's a
scary place to be
well you originated this conversation
with what's going to happen just think
from a macro perspective
are more people going to be working from
home or going back
less or more working from home long term
long term
two three five years from now are more
people gonna be working from home
versus where they were in 2019. well
here's obviously the answer is for sure
they're going to be working from home
more well here's one thing for sure that
cannot be happening if you're working
from home
if they do shut down with schools and
kids are staying home there's no way in
the world that's going to be working
from home it's just not going to work
out
if they're if they're not having kids go
home i'm talking two three years from
now there's a vaccine kids are back in
school
no i think yeah yeah offices i i think
you think but
not as much as they were in 2019 no
question about so meaning
this commercial office space the game is
if there was ninety percent
the game has changed now it'll be 70.
yeah
the game has changed